my canyons are great for the economy I
think that unions raise all workers
wages I think that unions protect
benefits for all workers and we also
give a voice on issues that do indeed
just literally impact other workers one
example of that is we've been fighting
in New Jersey for paid family leave for
ten years currently only two states in
the country offer it barring any
unforeseen disaster this March we will
see paid family leave voted into law and
hopefully signed by our governor and
that is legislation that has been
spearheaded by the labor movement that
will impact not just our members but
every working person in the state in a
positive way